[Musique]
imaginez
qu'on vous demande d'
expliquer l'histoire des
succursales de liaison à un gars de disons de
Denver
[Applaudissements]
je dirais que c'est l'histoire d'un homme
qui tombe amoureux de deux femmes,
il ne peut pas décider euh
laquelle choisir  être avec donc il tue pourriez-
vous dire
que vamo était votre personnage le plus
important de tous les temps
quand je fais quelque chose
sur scène ou un film ou quelque chose que je
fais comme ça
et je m'éloigne et celui-ci
est resté avec moi c'est  très
obsédant d'une certaine manière
euh c'est je veux dire que c'est
certainement la plus grande partie que j'ai faite dans le
film
mais ce n'est pas très important vraiment euh
ça
m'a en quelque sorte changé à certains égards je pense
personnellement que
vous et le vermont
partagez-vous ensemble et
Qu'est-ce qui vous divise ?
Je suis hyper conscient des effets
de mes actions  re
et velma manquent dans une certaine mesure de
conscience
je dirais et quand il trouve sa
conscience en
soi ça le tue il
y a un dicton en amérique le retour sur investissement
est une
chienne euh vous dites que sa
vie est comme celle du neurostar
sans noblesse il
occupe un  position spéciale ce que je voulais dire
par là
dans cet exemple, j'ai nommé
plusieurs choses qu'il pourrait être
vraiment je veux dire que vous pourriez être une rock star
une autre star politicienne
quelqu'un à la télévision une partie de la musique
et
toute personne qui a vraiment une position de
pouvoir ou un  statut élevé
basé sur
basé sur un mythe vraiment basé sur quelque chose
qu'ils ne sont pas
mais quelque chose qu'ils semblent être en d'
autres termes,
la noblesse n'avait évidemment
pas à être la noblesse de cette
décennie n'étaient pas nécessairement les personnes les plus
nobles
et pourtant elles étaient  élevé et
du même coup une star de cinéma qui est
très sexy n'est pas
nécessairement très sexy vraiment
je veux dire qu'ils peuvent être assez glacials en fait
ou
une star de cinéma qui semble très
dure et peu importe  r pourrait être gay
euh il s'agit d'
une position ou d'un
statut basé sur de fausses valeurs après les
bronzants de liaison vous pouvez maintenant
nous expliquer la différence entre l'amour
et le sexe
maintenant votre attitude envers les femmes est
différente depuis que vous êtes dans le vermont
maintenant si quelque chose i'  Je dis que je suis plus
terrifié par eux quel est le meilleur
souvenir que tu gardes du moment où
zephyrum a été tourné en france ma chambre
au raphael je
pense pourquoi tu n'irais pas voir un test pour voir
les films
je pense d'habitude  parce que
je pense toujours que je regarde un film
parce qu'ils ne parlent généralement de
rien de
très intéressant et donc
c'est très difficile pour moi de me
concentrer alors je
me lève juste et vais aux toilettes ou fume une
cigarette
ou quoi que ce soit  très plat parfois